[Musique]
bruno le maire tranquillement avec son
journal
je crois deviner l'équipe avec karim
benzema
une dans ce tweet de karim benzema n'y a
pas un mot mais pour didier deschamps
voilà pascal qui estime que c'est
incroyable je suis comme tous les
français
heureuse dans ma soirée une terrasse de
café lire mon journal
voilà c'est des moments de tranquillité
c'est le monde convivialité aussi on
voit je crois que les gens sont heureux
de se retrouver le terrasse de café
et puis je pense que cette fois ci c'est
la bonne je suis au café et il ya un bol
de cacahuètes partage on prend un du gel
à chaque fois qu'on prend quelqu'un non
non non ont fait tomber 5 bol de
cacahuètes et chips
ah oui belize et le bol de cacahuètes
c'est votre prescription doit vraiment
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'ils sont en
train de se dit à tous vous savez non
non non non mais certains vous êtes
certain tous qu'elles font plaisir ces
images pour le président le premier
ministre et une voie depuis ce matin
c'est de la com com faut rester prudent
et il faut réussir collectivement a
continué à maîtriser l'épidémie à côté
de ça on a surtout la vaccination qui se
poursuivent donc on n'est pas dans la
situer
du début d'année je risque il faut pas
se priver de se réjouir
oui parce qu'on revient de loin oui on
revient de loin mais rien n'est terminé
je suis optimiste sur nos sur les
conditions de réussite de ce
déconfinement je resterai prudence pour
vous dire si c'est complètement derrière
nous nous verrons l'automne prochain
voir l'hiver prochain si nous n'avons
pas de nouvelle vague de nouveaux
variants aidez nous on sait pas si c'est
zemmour mais si à elisabeth séville et
de villiers qui vont la manif pour la
police ou alors s'ils vont à la
conférence de rédaction de ces news et
monstration de force des organisations
syndicales avec cet après midi plusieurs
milliers de policiers massés devant
l'assemblée nationale sous couvert d'un
hommage au policier tué une
manifestation au caractère
ostensiblement factieux en ce sens
qu'elle s'en prend non pas aux causes
pour lesquelles ces malheureux ont été
assassinés mais aux institutions comme
l'institution judiciaire
on voit l'instant l'arrivée de gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur premier
flic de france c'est ainsi que
l'expression consacrée
expression alors évidemment c'est assez
inédit à trop milieu des manifestants
qui défendent ces revendications tout en
incarnant l'autorité publique n'est ce
pas un mélange des genres dangereux
gérald darmanin réponse en huit mois du
ministre je vais leur dire que nous les
aimons et tous les matins quand je me
lève tous les symboles le coup je pense
à vous j'ai été élu d'une ville
populaire où on sait que c'est grâce aux
policiers que ça tient donc n'ayez aucun
doute sur le soutien que j'apporte
opale voulez me faire dire que c'est du
jamais vu c'est assez inédit en tout cas
je pense que ça veut dire surtout une
chose c'est que le problème numéro un
c'est la réponse pénale il faut sortir
de cet écosystème laxistes en matière
pénale
et là encore nous regrettons que le
ministre de la justice préfère passer
son temps à mener une campagne
électorale plutôt qu'à s'occuper de
l'intégrité de nos forces de l'ordre
j'entends les réserves des uns et des
autres par rapport aux mots d'ordre par
rapport à la présence du rassemblement
national ou du ministre de l'intérieur
mais je refuse justement que ce que la
police soit livré aux manipulations de
l'extrême droite
je refuse qu'elle soit livrée à
l'instrumentalisation de ce gouvernement
ce qui me semble en revanche dangereux
pour notre démocratie c'est que l'on
oppose en permanence et à des fins
électoralistes et donc avec un certain
cynisme la justice et la police
74% des policiers se disent prêts à
voter est reine que vous inspire ce
chiffre est ce que c'est normal ou pas
il ya un fond d'oeil qu'il fasse en
créant une question comme ça ici devant
les policiers que c'est pas le moment de
faire de la politique